[Music]
each other crawling all over each other
oh you're beautiful every one of you is
a precious
snowflake happy Tuesday everyone so
we're less than two weeks into the new
year and not much has changed from 2023
I'm still under 7% body fat well done
kill me still rights at a fourth grade
level and the biggest threat on Earth
Big Orange monster man take this recent
piece from axios which points to the
former president as quote the risk that
trumps all others quote a second Trump
term would be far more radical than the
first committed to stretching legal and
governance boundaries and to pursuing
retribution for the prosecutions he's
been fighting since losing office
Trump's protectionist and isolationist
Tendencies would also terrify NATO while
creating an opening for China as a
global threat he is
unrivaled so how was is that a problem I
for one would like a second term that's
more radical than the first maybe we'll
get that wall we were promised huh and I
will get a cabinet position as Secretary
of
ABS 7% body fat maybe yeah there you go
but what's all this hysteria based on
you had four years of trump already
axios and none of your word salad
happened but also neither did war
doesn't that count for something but if
they admitted that they couldn't create
a distraction by preaching imaginary
Doom and Gloom which brings me to
Michelle Obama the former first lady is
now super afraid so what is going to
happen in the next election I bet she's
terrified about what can possibly happen
what's going to happen in this next
election I am terrified about what could
possibly happen because our leaders
matter who we select who speaks for us
who holds that bullied Pulpit it affects
us in ways that sometimes I think people
take for granted true Barack so scared
he changed his name back to Barry
sotero but no doubt Michelle's scared
scared the Dems are going to lose
because the real problem for Michelle is
people are stupid because you know the
fact that people think that government
you know doesn't really do anything and
I'm like oh my God you know the fact
that people think that government n you
know is it does it really do anything
and I'm like oh my God does government
do everything for us and we cannot take
this democracy for granted and sometimes
I I worry that we do those are the
things that keep me up that tells you
all you need to know about Democrats
people are the problem and the
government is always the solution and
guess what side Michelle's aligned with
and sure the government wants to do
everything for us but that doesn't mean
they must that's not the point of this
country we're individuals not cogs we we
are a free people free to pursue our
aims without the intrusiveness of an
Ever encroaching power mad government
which is why our side doesn't feel
compelled to call 911 when we're
misgendered she says we cannot take this
democracy for granted and sometimes I
worry that we do which confuses me
aren't people trying to vote for Trump
and isn't her party that's preventing
that that's the idiocy in a nutshell how
can we have a democracy when people can
vote for whoever they want that's like
saying I don't objectif by women as long
as they're not fat or
unattractive and Trump's so scary you
can't even debate him that's what some
Dem say claiming it'll just expose his
extremist views you know like speaking
coherently and not shaking hands with
dead
people but let's be honest they've seen
Joe on stage get taken out by a sandbag
imagine what Trump will do to him I
wonder what else keeps Michelle up the
things she
knows what keeps me up are the things
that I know um the war in the region in
too many regions what is AI going to do
for us the environment you know are we
moving at all fast enough what are we
doing about education are people going
to vote and why aren't people voting are
we too stuck to our phones I mean those
are the things that keep me up because
you you don't have control over
them she needs some relaxium Wars in too
many regions which have all started
within the last three years haven't they
what a coincidence she's like let's keep
the wars where they belong in this
country against bakeries and parents
education she's got a point there but
that's why we've got parents showing up
at PTA meetings angry about the crap
their kids are being taught by her
fellow woke Knuckleheads when Trump was
President 2 plus two equal four now it
equals hormone shots and crossdress
Thursdays of course what she's really
scared about is losing in control and if
Trump wins boy will she without
mentioning him by name she said this the
tone and tener of the message matters we
can't just say what what the first thing
that comes to our minds we cannot that
is not authenticity to me that's that's
childish and we see childish leadership
right before us what that looks like and
how that feels where somebody is just
base and vulgar and cynical in a
leadership
[Music]
position but she's right we can't have
politicians who behave like children
Democrats will try to transition them so
2024 is starting to look like a rematch
between the same two dudes the
difference is one wants you to vote for
him and the other wants to stop you from
voting for anyone who's not him but the
truth is them say this crap about every
Republican every election even mitt was
Hitler for a while remember when they
accused Romney of giving a lady cancer
and they actually claimed mitt was evil
for putting his dog on the roof of his
car that is until someone pointed out
that Obama had put dogs on the roof of
his
[Laughter]
mouth yeah Obama want ate a dog he
bragged about it in one of his
biographies and away from the dinner
table I was roduced to dog meat tough
snake meat tougher and roasted
grasshopper
crunchy but how smooth is Barack working
the dog eating with snakes and crickets
like we wouldn't notice yeah I'll have a
Cricut salad some fried snake and Old
Yeller again the DS keep predicting how
terrifying Trump will be as if he wasn't
already president once when things were
better they're hyping a horror movie
when it's the sequel to A feel-good
comedy with punch lines but no bread
lines they want to blame everything on
him but the truth is he mostly left us
alone and that's what we all want to be
left alone Trump didn't tell you what
kind of car to drive or food to eat he
didn't care if he didn't like Big Max
that meant more for
him look I don't want the government
doing pretty much anything for me
because they suck at everything well
everything but lying and dividing and
while they worry about Trump they ignore
what's truly scary like how this thing
that does everything for us can't keep
track of anything the trillions they
printed out and gave out during covid
the millions of illegals the crime on
our streets our secretary of defense
this White House couldn't even keep
cocaine out of the White House if this
administration were your babysitter
you'd come home and your kid would be
drunk missing and on puberty
blockers that's the government that
keeps demanding to help me no thanks
I'll take my chances at least with
Republicans they know government sucks
which makes them better at it hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else